RYAN BOYD: So I'm going to
start off by giving an
introduction to the
cloud platform.
Like I mentioned, this is in a
general sense how the cloud
platform works, how the
pieces fit together.
And we're also going to invite
the folks up from Leanplum
towards the end of this session
to talk about how they
do A/B testing to do mobile app
optimization and how they
build that all on top of
the cloud platform.
Although we have some
third-party presenters coming
up here, game developers,
they're talking a little bit
about their products.
But they're also going to really
dive into and give you
some best practices
around how you can
build apps on the platform.
If you have any questions, we're
going to save some time
for Q&A at the end.
But you can also reach
out to us online.
There is my Google+ handle, as
well as my Twitter handle.
And feel free to ask
me any questions.
We'll also be here throughout
the day and available at lunch
and that sort of thing.
So the Google Cloud Platform--
the Google Cloud Platform is
all about using Google's
underlying infrastructure.
Google's underlying
infrastructure is really the
backbone which makes
Google great.
We've put a lot of time invested
into how do we build
better data centers, how do we
build faster computers, how we
can push computer science
further than it's gone before.
We've spent the last 14 years
doing this and building up
data center footprints around
the world and building up a
lot of expertise into how to
run those data centers.
And not only are those data
centers fast, efficient,
secure, and things like that.
But they're also quite pretty,
as you can see here.
These are pictures taken--
there's a "Wired" article you
can look up for Wired Google
data centers.
There's a lot of great insights
into how our data
centers work in that article and
some more pretty pictures.
Well that was very nice of it.
Let's see if we can--
I have to remember to disable
Software Update here.
There we go.
So there's a "Wired" article.
Check it out, read up about our
data centers, but we have
built up a lot of expertise over
the last 14 years with
these data centers.
And not only have we built up
expertise in the hardware and
the infrastructure that it
requires to run these data
centers, we've also built up
expertise in the software--
how we can create highly
scalable and reliable software
that really uses the power
of Google's data centers.
We've released a lot of that
software as academic white
papers and open-source
projects.
As well as commercial products
have actually implemented
these academic white papers.
But we've also then taken that
knowledge and made this
software available to
you as services.
And these services are
what the Google Cloud
Platform is all about.
So I've broken up the services
on the cloud platform in three
different blocks here.
So we have compute, we have
storage, and then other types
of services.
On the compute side, this is
really where you can run your
own software, where you can
develop software that runs on
Google's infrastructure and
takes advantage of that
experience.
And we have two different
types here.
The first that you'll see
mentioned is Compute Engine.
Compute Engine is virtual
machines.
So you can run any type
of software you want.
You have the ultimate
in flexibility.
You have Linux-based
virtual machines.
If you have legacy software, if
you're building new things
that require a lot of
specialized development,
Compute Engine is
where it's at.
But we've also developed
App Engine.
And App Engine is our platform
as a service environment that
allows you to build applications
without having to
worry about the system
administration side, without
having to worry about
maintaining the servers and
dealing with downtime or
anything like that.
All you have to worry about is
writing the application logic
that makes your game
or business great.
You can concentrate on
that while Google
concentrates on the rest.
And we're going to be talking
about that and the different
services that are available
to you as part of
App Engine here shortly.
Then of course, storage is
key to most applications.
Most applications just don't
need the business logic.
They need storage to store
underlying user data or other
types of data.
And we have three different
types of storage offerings
that I've pictured here.
First is cloud storage.
Objects-- if you have image
assets, video assets, things
like that, that you need to
serve to your users, you can
store them as objects
and have them
available around the world.
You can also do a relational
database on top of the Google
Cloud Platform.
That's what Cloud
SQL is about.
It's a MySQL-based relational
database that gives you high
availability of your relational
database.
But if you truly want to
scale, that's what the
datastore is all about.
It's a NoSQL database that
scales really, really well for
applications that need to handle
lots of user traffic.
And then in the services bucket
here, we have a variety
of other services that
Google offers.
Our goal is to really make
lives easier for you as
developers.
We wanted to make it faster
for you to build your
applications, allow you to
concentrate on the core
technology that makes your
applications great.
And so these services handle a
lot of the common tasks, as
well as those tasks that would
be difficult for developers to
build on their own.
So BigQuery allows you to crunch
terabytes of data for
your application.
Cloud Endpoints allows you
to build APIs on Google's
infrastructure using the same
API infrastructure that we use
for things like Google Drive
and YouTube and Google+.
And then you have other things,
lower-level services,
like caching and queuing.
And we're going to talk about
some more here later.
And then of course, the cloud
platform gives you access to a
whole wide variety of other
Google services that you see
pictured at the top right.
And all of this is hosted on top
of Google's infrastructure
and gives you the same sort of
reliability and security that
Google expects for
its own services.
So I'm going to step through
each of these individual
services now and talk to you
in a little bit more detail
about these services.
This is still an overview
presentation.
You'll get more and more detail
later in the other
sessions, as people go into how
to build games on these
applications.
But the first service I want to
talk to you about here is
Google App Engine.
Google App Engine is that
platform as a service
environment.
It's an opinionated framework
that allows you to build
applications, while worrying
just about your application
code and not worrying about
system administration and
things like that.
So our goal with App Engine is
make it easy for you to build,
scale, and maintain
your applications.
On the easy to build side, we
have SDKs in a variety of
different programming
languages.
We have SDKs available in
Python, Java, and Go.
And it provides a local
development server.
That's one of the key things
that we decided was really
important when we launched App
Engine was allow you to
develop and iterate quickly
in your local environment.
So you can run up a local
development server in Eclipse
and do almost all the same
things that you can do if your
application is deployed.
And then of course, in making
it easy to build, it also
means that we have to make it
easy for you to manage and
understand what's going on
in your application.
So there's great easy management
with the App Engine
console and logs that really
provide you access to all the
things that's going
on underneath the
covers in App Engine.
When exceptions are thrown,
you can easily dive
into them, et cetera.
So the services, though, is
really what it's about when it
comes to a platform
as a service.
If you have to write every
line of code for your
application, or use a lot of
the common libraries out
there, but still run all the
services that your application
requires, that means that
you have to spend a
lot of extra time--
a lot of extra time maintaining
those services.
So things like Memcache--
Memcache is something that you
can easily run yourself.
But it's easy to run yourself
in a way to get it up and
running, but it's not easy to
run day to day in a production
environment.
So we actually provide a
Memcache Service for you that
allows you to optimize your
applications for performance.
And we maintain all
those servers
necessary for this to happen.
You just have to write a handful
of lines of code.
We also provide other things
like email support--
makes it easy to send email.
Images--
if you want to scale or rotate
images and things like that,
you can use the same
infrastructure that Google
uses for that.
The datastore we talked about--
there's XMPP support.
Task queues is one of the
commonly used things.
So if you have logic that you
want to run, but it doesn't
necessarily need to run right
away, it can run later.
There's task queues both in
a push and a pull fashion.
So a lot of different types of
services that you can take
advantage of that Google has
built for our own purposes and
now we're opening up for you.
Cloud Endpoints is probably one
of my favorite services
that we're opening up.
Cloud Endpoints takes advantage
of our internal API
infrastructure.
So when I started at Google
about six years ago, we had
API infrastructure where it was
basically a common set of
libraries for all the APIs to
build their APIs on top of.
So the calendar API or the
contacts API were built on top
of a common set of libraries.
More recently, we've made it a
common service that all the
Google product teams can
take advantage of.
So when they build their APIs,
we have central API servers
that manage all that
environment, make sure the
protocol is the same, make sure
it's easy for developers,
internally, to build
these APIs.
But more recently, we've made
this same infrastructure
available to you.
So you can build Google-style
APIs on our infrastructure and
take advantage of all that
knowledge that we've learned
creating dozens and dozens
of APIs on the same
infrastructure.
So you can write your business
logic in Google App Engine.
And then you can have clients in
Android or iOS or in Chrome
and any browser, for
that matter.
And those clients can access
your APIs that you've built
with simple business logic
provided by App Engine.
So here's what that business
logic requires.
And this is why I included
this in the
easy to build category.
Because all you really need to
do to launch an API on Google,
using Cloud Endpoints, is
annotate some of your code.
You annotate your code to
say, hey this is an API.
You can see here this
tic-tac-toe API.
We're defining it as an
API named tictactoe.
We have versioning support,
description, et cetera.
And then you're just annotating
your method to say,
this method called board.
board.getmove is the RPC-style
way of calling it.
And that's what you do
to build an API on
top of Cloud Endpoints.
So Dan will get into this a
lot more, in a lot more
detail, here later.
But this is really awesome that
you're able to use all of
our API serving infrastructure
to build your own APIs and
have clients from mobile
apps or web
applications accessing them.
Now, App Engine has really been
optimized for scaling
your application for front-end
type requests, a lot of web
requests that are really
quick to respond to.
But we've also heard the need
for more and more back-end
processing.
And that's actually why we
released App Engine Backends,
which allows you to run
continuous tasks in the
background without any sort of
deadlines for how long those
requests can take and
that sort of thing.
So if we go in a progression
here, App Engine provides
great front-end web services,
with their front ends.
The Backends allows you a little
bit more flexibility by
keeping things longer running.
And then later, I'm going to
talk about Compute Engine,
which allows you the ultimate in
flexibility by controlling
your code at the VM level.
So App Engine's development
stack--
the Eclipse plugin I
mentioned already.
But we've also worked with a
variety of other companies and
technologies to make a
development stack that's
really easy for you
understand.
And even as we move towards the
future here, and we decide
that we don't want to actually
have to have an ID installed
on all our computers.
We want to just be able to
open up your Chromebook.
We actually have, I think, a
Pixel around here somewhere.
But if you want to just open up
your Chromebook and want to
write some code, we've worked
with Codenvy to build
integration with App Engine
into Codenvy so that right
within a browser, you can both
write your code and deploy
your code onto Google
App Engine.
This is an awesome quote here.
"With Google App Engine, we
don't need a system
administrator or anyone
dedicated to deploying our app,
so 99% of our time is
spent working on our
application." This is from Ben
Kamens on Khan Academy.
Khan Academy became
pretty wildly
successful for online learning.
And they really don't actually
hire system administrators.
They just hire the people
that write their code.
App Engine does the system
administration for them.
They can concentrate on writing
their code and making
online learning really
powerful for
people to get new skills.
So Ben is a really awesome
developer, as well.
If you ever get a chance to meet
him, tell him that the
App Engine team says hi.
So making your application easy
to build isn't just about
dealing with the code.
Making your application easy to
build is also about dealing
with some of the policy stuff
and all that you have to deal
with as application developers,
specifically when
it comes to storing
user information.
The EU has a lot of regulations
about that.
And one thing we've done
recently is actually open up
European data centers and allow
you to specify that your
code runs only in those data
centers and your data at rest
is only in those data centers.
So this makes it a lot easier
for you to comply with the
applicable regulations for
storing user data and is very
important for a lot of
European developers.
So we've talked about how it's
easy to build on the
technology side, on a little
bit of the policy side.
Now let's talk about how
it's easy to scale your
applications with App Engine.
You might not think scaling
is that important.
If you're building your
application, you might not
think initially you're going
to get a lot of users.
You might build your application
such that you can
say, well, I'll deal with
scaling later, when I get a
bunch of traffic.
But I'm going to give you
a couple use cases where
developers have decided
that they did
need to build to scale.
And it's worked out really
well for them.
So you probably have traffic
charts that look
something like this.
You have spikes, whether it be
advertising campaigns, whether
it be a new release, or
things like that.
You have spikes in
your traffic.
And you have to decide,
hey, do you need to
have a couple servers?
Do you need to have a couple
spare servers sitting around,
a bunch of replicas?
How many servers do you need,
in case of surges?
And oftentimes, what that ends
up being is you're either
over-provisioned or
under-provisioned for your traffic.
And App Engine is really about
getting around this problem
and allowing you to scale to the
level of traffic that your
application needs to scale.
So we're constantly just
launching new instances as
your application gets more and
more traffic and making sure
your application can handle
that traffic.
And that's one of the beautiful
things about App Engine.
So Getaround--
Getaround is a car-sharing
company.
I think they initially started
off with this model where you
rent cars from other people
in your neighborhood.
And I actually just passed one
this morning, the first time I
saw one near my house.
It appears that they've also
moved into a model where they
maintain some of the
cars, as well.
But Getaround built
their application,
at first, in a hackathon.
They had two days to build
an application.
They built a mobile app, and
they built their backend, on
App Engine, in those two days.
And that application was already
ready for scaling.
They built using App Engine as
that opinionated framework to
get the scale that
they needed.
And then when it came around
to the TechCrunch Disrupt
Contest, they had a 30x increase
in traffic, when they
won the TechCrunch
Disrupt Contest.
And there was a lot of
celebration, a lot of partying.
You can see here they're popping
champagne on stage.
With that 30x increase in
traffic, they were able to
drink their champagne and
not have to worry
about getting paged.
They didn't get paged once
during this, because App
Engine automatically
handled scaling out
their traffic for them.
And that's really the beautiful
thing about the
scaling with App Engine, is you
can drink champagne and
not worry about answering
your pages.
So everyone that's carrying
a pager around
here, think about that.
So if it's easy to build,
it's easy to scale.
Now let's talk about maintaining
your application.
So one of the key things you
have to do when you maintain
your application is actually
understand where your
performance bottlenecks are,
understand what is taking up
the most time in your
application.
And that's what AppStats is all
about-- being able to dive
in to all your different
requests and figure out which
are the bottlenecks in your
application and then figure
out how to improve those.
So AppStats--
there's a quote here at the
top right. "I used to be
blind, but now I can see." And
that's really what we want
developers to be able to do.
Although it's an opinionated
framework, and Google deals
with a lot of these things for
you, there's ways that you can
build your application that
aren't the most highly
performant.
And AppStats allows you to see
when you're doing that and
really fix those problems.
We've also worked in the
deployment space here of
making it easy to deploy
your application
with CloudBees Jenkins.
So we've worked with them.
And if you want to auto build
and deploy your application,
these guys can handle it.
And overall, developers
are loving App Engine.
We're getting a lot of
increase in traffic.
We'll show that to you here.
As we've released more and more
features on App Engine,
over time you can see the graph
of our traffic goes up
and up and up.
As we initially started off with
just Python run times,
and then we added Java and Go
support, added all these
different services which make it
easy for you to build your
application.
We're now up to the point of 7
and 1/2 billion hits a day.
And if you think about a month
in the world of App Engine,
over 1 million active
applications, 2 trillion
datastore operations, half
of the world's active IP
addresses, touch App Engine
in any given month.
And you can see here we have
companies everywhere from
small businesses and startups to
big enterprises to consumer
good companies.
So that's how you can build
on a platform as a service
environment where Google is
handling a lot of the scaling
for you, Google is handling
a lot of the system
administration for you.
But sometimes you need ultimate
flexibility, having
raw access to virtual
machines.
And that's what Compute
Engine is all about.
So at a high level, Compute
Engine is an infrastructure as
a service offering.
It allows you to run virtual
machines directly on Google's
infrastructure.
And we consider Compute Engine
really great for things like
large scale analysis,
batch processing, or
variable size workloads.
And variable size workloads
can be a lot
of different things.
It could be game backends,
for instance.
But we think of the users of
Compute Engine as those that
want to really take advantage
of all of our expertise that
we've built up in building out
infrastructure, in building
out the ability to do super fast
networking and I/O, and
that sort of thing.
And so Compute Engine is built
for that, but it's also built
for ease of use.
And this is a high-level diagram
of Compute Engine,
where we have the overview, or
container, is our project.
And this is a project
that you get with
the Google APIs consoles.
So if you've ever built
applications on top of Google,
you go to the APIs console,
and you set up a project.
And you turn on what APIs you
want to have access to.
And that's the same
container that we
have for Compute Engine.
So any given project has a set
of VMs associated with that
project, has disks,
has network.
And all of that is controlled
for access using standard
Google accounts.
So you can go in.
And you can set which
Google accounts
or groups have access.
And you can do this either using
regular Google accounts
or even Google Apps accounts.
And as soon as I add--
if I added one of you guys, over
there, to my project that
has virtual machines associated
with it, you could
immediately SSH into those
virtual machines.
There's no more work
that's required.
We automatically handle
the key generation
and things like that.
And then of course, we have a
standard set of APIs, using
the same API infrastructure I
was talking about earlier,
that allows you to control your
instances, allows you to
control your network,
and allows you to
control your storage.
But at its heart, this is really
just virtual machines.
Later, we're going to go into
some more detail about how
people have used these virtual
machines in order to build
things that are unique and
some quotes from some
customers about how they can
scale and perform faster than
other virtual machine
technologies they've used.
But I won't go into much
more detail here.
Because it's virtual machines.
You guys get access to the
same underlying virtual
machine infrastructure
that Google uses.
There's actually a question
in the audience, here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, on the
networking layer, how granular
can you go [INAUDIBLE]?
RYAN BOYD: Right now, there's
not too granular access to
control that.
But it is definitely something
that we're looking at.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
RYAN BOYD: Yep.
So you may wonder, can you get
access to Compute Engine?
Compute Engine is in a limited
preview state right now.
We are providing SLA and
support for commercial
customers during this
limited preview.
And you can apply
for access here.
But your best way is come and
talk to us later today, tell
us what your use case is,
and apply online.
And we'll see if it's a good
fit for Compute Engine.
But we're getting more and more
customers every day onto
Compute Engine.
And they're loving it.
So we talked about how you
can run your code.
The next thing, if
we [? followed ?]
the progression from the
original diagram, is talking
about how you deal with data
on the cloud platform.
And we have a bunch
of services for
dealing with this.
So first is your standard
databases.
So there's a NoSQL datastore.
The NoSQL datastore
is available
directly from App Engine.
And this allows you to get the
super high level of scale that
many types of applications want
to achieve when they're
launching on App Engine.
But we've learned that a
number of folks don't
understand or don't
want to understand
the whole NoSQL paradigm.
They want to think in terms
of regular SQL.
They want to do relational
databases.
And that's why we launched
Cloud SQL.
Cloud SQL is essentially a
hosted MySQL offering.
It provides high availability
that Google expects for its
own services.
And it's fully managed for you,
so you don't have to deal
with how to configure your MySQL
servers and replication
and things like that.
But basically, both of these are
accessible from the cloud
platform and provide the way you
want to access your data.
And then of course, there's
the object storage that I
talked about.
And this is Google Cloud
Storage, allows you to store
arbitrary numbers of objects--
very large objects, very
small objects--
allows you to store it and have
it accessible through
Google's network and
[? throughoutside ?]
of the internet from
around the world.
And this cloud storage uses
the same sort of paradigms
that we talked about earlier
with how we manage our
projects with the
APIs console.
And it also allows you to
configure your access control
lists and things like that
really easily to any Google
account or even service account,
so applications can
have access directly to cloud
storage on behalf of the
application.
So you're storing data
for your application.
You then maybe get a little bit
more data, and more data,
and more data.
And you want to be able to
analyze large amounts of data.
You want to be able to analyze
big data on the
Google Cloud Platform.
And that's what BigQuery
is all about--
more and more data, more
and more data.
And big data at Google-- what
does it mean to us?
The theme of this is a lot of
the technologies that Google
has built, we're making
available to you.
So let's talk about what big
data means to Google.
Every minute there
are 72 hours of
video uploaded to YouTube.
Think about that for a moment.
That's a lot of video-- a lot of
cat videos, in particular.
There are 100 million
gigabytes in the
Google search index.
And that was back in 2010.
And there are 425 million
users of Gmail.
And all of these products,
we want to iterate on.
We want to take this data and
turn it into meaning.
We want to allow our product
managers and our engineers
easy access to understand how
the products are being used
and iterate on them-- much the
same as you want to do when
building your games.
And so a lot of our product
managers and engineers have
familiarity with SQL.
So they want to be able to run
familiar types of SQL queries
on their data to understand
what's happening with their
products and improve them.
But they need to be able
to run it fast.
They need to be able to crunch
data at Google scale.
It's not your typical
database.
They need to be able to
sit here, scan 100
gigabytes in 10 seconds.
And we'll show you even
better here shortly.
So what they do here, what
originally people would do if
they're trying to run queries
across their data, is run them
in a single server.
But Google said,
you know what?
We don't just have
a single server.
We have tons of servers.
We have hundreds, thousands of
servers around the world.
And we want our queries to be
able to run on all of those.
And that's what BigQuery is
about-- being able to scale
and parallelize queries to
be able to run on lots of
different machines.
So BigQuery gives you
the same power.
We use that underlying
technology, called Dremel,
internally.
But now we're opening it up to
you as BigQuery, to store your
data with the reliability,
redundancy, and consistency
that you expect and Google
expects for its own data, to
go from data to meaning,
at scale, quickly.
And let me actually show you
what at scale quickly means in
the context of BigQuery here.
So Wikipedia is kind enough
to provide access
to their log files.
So when you visit a Wikipedia
page, it records something in
their log files.
And they provide these log files
for people to download
and analyze.
I think it's about 5 or 6
terabytes of total data.
And I put these log files
into BigQuery.
And what this query is that
you're seeing here is looking
at about a year of those logs--
actually, 13 months of
those logs.
It's 1 terabyte of table data.
And in that 1 terabyte of data,
what I'm looking for is
some particular columns.
And I want to do a regular
expression match on the title
of the Wikipedia pages to find
all those pages that start
with a capital G, have a
lowercase O, and end with a
lowercase E.
And I want to do that query and
figure out what are the
number of page views.
What are the top viewed
pages where the title
matches that pattern?
So it's a typical, standard
SQL query
that I'm running here--
grouping by the title.
And I'm running this query
across these tables.
In these tables, there are 15.7
billion rows of data.
I am running 15.7 billion
regular expressions.
There's no indexes here.
We're reading off that
data off of disk.
Because I'm only accessing some
of the columns here, we
don't have to read all 1
terabyte of data off of disk.
We're only reading--
and "only" is important here--
only reading 665 gigabytes of
data off of disk.
And we did that all
in 12.2 seconds.
16 billion regular expressions,
12.2 seconds,
reading 665 gigabytes
of data off of disk.
Isn't that impressive?
That's really what Google's
infrastructure is all about.
How many of you could imagine
doing that in
your relational database?
Anyone?
If you can, I'm curious
to talk with you.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, certainly if
you're doing queries at this
scale, it does use
a lot of money.
Because it uses a lot
of infrastructure.
But it's important that you have
the power to be able to
do interactive queries like
this, if you do have a year's
worth of data to crunch.
And so 12.2 seconds, 15.7
billion rows of data.
Let's see.
Let me get back to this.
So developers are using this
technology for a lot of
different things-- game and
social media analytics,
infrastructure monitoring,
advertising campaign
optimization, sensor
data analysis.
A lot of the same types of use
cases where Google uses this
technology internally, we've
found developers
using it, as well.
BigQuery, at its heart,
is a RESTful API.
I just showed you the web
interface for how to access
BigQuery, but that's actually
not what we're building.
We're not building a web
interface for users to be able
to access their data.
We're building a
developer tool.
And this developer tool
is a RESTful API.
So you can build this same
technology into your own
applications.
And the folks from Leanplum are
going to talk about how
they've used BigQuery in their
application here in a second.
Underneath this, basically,
it's a REST API.
You're uploading your data
to Google Cloud Storage.
You're making an API call to
BigQuery and telling BigQuery
to load in that data off
of cloud storage.
Your data can be in a
standard CSV format.
Or it also can be in a JSON
format with nested and
repeated data--
flexibility there.
But as soon as you load your
data into BigQuery, there's no
indexes or anything we
have to perform.
Your data is immediately
accessible.
So I've loaded many terabytes
of data into BigQuery, once
it's already on cloud storage,
in a half hour.
And that makes it super
flexible that you can
instantly start running your
queries and not have to wait
days for indexes to build.
There's also libraries in
a variety of different
programming languages.
So if you recognize your
favorite programming language
here, there's libraries already
available for you.
But of course, there's the
RESTful API if you want to
integrate directly.
Now I'm going to invite up
Momchil and Andrew from
Leanplum to talk about how
they've integrated with the
Google Cloud Platform-- in
particular, how they've
integrated with App Engine
and BigQuery.
[? Switch over. ?]
MOMCHIL KYURKCHIEV:
Hi, everyone.
My name is Momchil.
I'm a founder and
CEO of Leanplum.
And I'm here today with
my co-founder, Andrew.
And we're building a platform
to enable mobile game
companies to understand and
monetize their users better
through A/B testing.
And in this talk today, we'll
show you how we're
transforming the way companies
optimize their mobile games.
But we'll also crack the door
open slightly to show you how
we built all of this on the
Google Cloud Platform.
But before I start, let
me tell you a little
bit about our team.
Both Andrew and I have a
technical background, with
several years of experience
actually optimizing
video ads at Google.
And our third co-founder, Joel,
on the left side there--
he's a former VC at Redpoint.
And he heads our sales
and [? biz dev. ?]
And our domain expertise is
A/B testing and building
scalable infrastructure.
So all of you are familiar
with the
concept of A/B testing.
And the idea is that you split
your users in two groups--
group A and group B. You give
each group a different
product, or a different version
of your product.
And then you measure
the result.
And while A/B testing is a very
popular concept on the
web, we realized that this is
not the case on mobile.
And so we wanted to understand
why that's the case.
And so here's the problem.
Imagine you're a product
manager for a game.
Every day, you're faced with
decisions that affect the
revenue of your product.
But to test what works the best,
first you need to talk
to your developers to get them
to make the changes for you,
which is, of course,
complicated
and takes some time.
And then you get the
changes done.
And you still need to wait for
two weeks to submit your app
to the app store.
And then finally, you run your
tests, get the results back,
and you need to analyze them to
figure out if the results
are statistically significant.
And with Leanplum, we solved
these three problems.
We enabled product managers to
run tests in real time, right
from our dashboard.
And we interpret the
results for them.
And so let me show you
how this works.
Let's say you've got a game
with in app purchases, and
you're interested in optimizing
your revenue.
One thing you can decide to
change, or test, is to try
different prices and colors for
the items in your store.
You can see that it's very easy
to choose what percentage
of users will see
each version.
Now, you can make changes right
from our dashboard.
You don't have to talk to your
developers or wait for Apple
to approve your changes.
And all of this happens
in real time.
You type in the new price, and
it goes live automatically.
And the same thing happens for
the color of the particular
energy [? recharge ?] you're
trying to change.
And when the test is done,
you'll get a report showing
which metrics have changed and
with what confidence interval.
And a change like this can
actually increase your revenue
by as much as 20%.
And we've rethought the way
analytics should be done with
optimization at the core.
It starts with the technology
we've built in our backend.
And again, Andrew will cover
that more in detail.
But we allow very flexible
queries, in real time.
And all this package is
presented into a delightful
product that's oriented
around the needs
of the product manager.
And now you can optimize things
like game dynamics,
artwork, messaging,
and economies.
And you can set up hundreds of
these tests all in real time.
Now, this shouldn't
be news to you.
But mobile is becoming a
lot more competitive.
And there is more than 200,000
games on the market.
And the winners are going to be
separated from the losers,
based on who can optimize
their games the best.
In addition to that, we have
a revenue model shift here
that's from paid apps
to free to play.
And optimization is the
key to unlocking
this new revenue source.
So how are we doing so far?
We're currently working with
several companies as part of
our private beta.
And they range from the hundreds
of companies who
signed up on our website to
marquee customers such as Big
Fish Games.
Today, we are announcing
the availability
of our Android SDK.
And we're also extending an
offer to companies here at GDC
to join our beta, which is
still a private beta.
You can sign up at our URL
here, leanplum.com/gdc.
And we'll be happy to set up
some one on one time with you,
walk through your use case and
also show you a demo and get
you access.
And with that, I'd like to
hand over to Andrew.
Actually, I'll sit over here.
ANDREW FIRST: Hi, everyone.
I'm Andrew.
I'm one of the co-founders
of Leanplum.
So we're going to switch gears a
little bit and tell you more
about how we built our system
using some of Google's cloud
services and share some our
learnings along the way.
So when we initially considered
what technologies
to use for Leanplum, we had the
following criteria in mind.
So first, it should
be easy to build a
minimum viable product.
It should have a low
upfront cost.
It should be easy to use.
And it should scale well, as
we were anticipating having
massive traffic spikes as we
signed up new customers into
our service.
So as we were out evaluating
technologies, we found that
App Engine filled all
these requirements.
So it was easy to set up, had
zero upfront costs, and it
handled scaling automatically.
And additionally, we were
already familiar with the
technology, because we were
working at Google beforehand.
But it's also a pretty familiar
Django [? stack ?] to
anyone who's built Python
apps before.
So now let me walk you through
how we ended up building our
service using some of
Google's services.
So first, we started with a
simple website that needed a
login system.
And App Engine already provided
an easy to use login
system using the user's API.
That used a Google account
authentication system, so we
didn't have to build out account
creation or deal with
users who ended up forgetting
their passwords.
So it was very simple
to get set up.
And then next, we needed a way
to serve content into the app,
as people needed to
make changes to
their app on the fly.
And so we needed a way to
serve files at scale.
And the Blobstore API
was really good
at doing just that.
Then next, we needed a way to
keep track of the different
metrics in the app that would
ultimately be optimized.
So for example, when a new
session started, it would need
to write the session object and
then increment a counter.
And so for that, we used the
Datastore API that Ryan talked
about earlier-- the datastore's
built on Google's
BigTable, internally.
But there was a problem.
The datastore is really great at
key value storage, but not
so great for incrementing
counters.
So every time you need to
increment a counter, you need
to create a transaction where
first, you retrieve the
existing value of the counter.
And then you have to update the
new value simultaneously.
And unfortunately, because of
that, there's a limit on the
number of transactions you
can run per second
on any given object.
So to get around that, we
used the Memcache API.
So Memcache provides an atomic
way to do increments.
So for increment encounters,
we used Memcache.
And then we took the values from
Memcache and then updated
the datastore counters.
So we got around the transaction
limit that way.
And then to run a report, we
would essentially run a query
over the different counters
in the datastore.
The datastore already provides
built-in indexing
and querying support.
But you can only query on the
fields that you index.
So if you want to run arbitrary
queries on an
arbitrary set of fields,
then you would need an
index for each one.
And so you would need hundreds
and hundreds of indexes, which
would be very expensive
to maintain.
So we needed, essentially, a
data warehouse system, where
we could run these arbitrary
queries in near real time.
And so for that, we used the
MapReduce API, which comes
with App Engine, to collect all
the sessions and then feed
that data into Google
BigQuery.
Which as Ryan talked about
earlier, BigQuery allows you
to run custom queries on your
data very, very fast.
Next we needed to make
our front end more
interactive, as well.
And so for that, we used the
Channels API, which allows you
to communicate from your
backend to the front
end, in real time.
So as people are testing out
events on their devices, they
can see the graphs actually
update instantaneously.
Then next, we needed a way to
encrypt our traffic, as
companies were worried about
people cheating in their game.
It was very easy
to set up SSL.
Because App Engine is all
managed, we didn't have to
write extra code or install
anything on our servers to get
that to work.
And then finally, we needed
a way to email our users.
For example, when a user got
added to a team, they needed
to be notified how to sign in.
And so the Mail API provides
you an easy way to send
emails, at scale.
So now that we had the basics
down, we needed to further
optimize our service
to improve latency
and reduce the costs.
So here, I'm going to share some
of the discoveries that
we made as we were developing
on Google App Engine.
So first, App Engine
provides a really
great way to do logging.
It logs every single request and
all the logging statements
in your app, so you can
see it all on the
dashboard in one place.
Then you can go and filter it.
And you can also just view it--
view just the errors to
see what might have gone
wrong in your app.
It also provides something
called AppStats, which Ryan
showed earlier, which allows you
to break down the requests
that you make in your app by
every individual API call
along a timeline.
So you can see which calls take
the longest, which ones
cost the most.
So you can find the bottlenecks
and optimize those
in your backend.
And after using the AppStats
tool, we actually discovered
that a lot of the time spent was
on waiting for datastore
objects to be written.
And that actually didn't need
to be on the critical path.
So for example, when a new
session started, we didn't
actually need the user to
wait for the session
object to get written.
So we actually used the task
queue to defer some of that
work until later.
And so that moved it off
the critical path.
And we significantly cut
down on latency.
And some other tips for
optimizing your app-- one, if
you don't need every field to be
indexed in your datastore,
you can choose for those fields
not to get indexed.
And then you can save a lot of
money on datastore writes.
Because it won't need to write
those indexes every time.
Second, if you can anticipate
how many front end instance
hours you're going to be
using, you can actually
reserve those up front.
So you can get a discount
on the cost of
the front end instances.
And then finally, if you're
tending to read the same
object over and over, you should
use the Memcache, which
is a lower latency from the
datastore, and it's also free.
And so what's next for us?
Well, as we build out more
sophisticated features and
more complex data processing,
we're looking into using
Google Compute Engine
for that.
It provides a lot more powerful
instances compared to
the App Engine front
end instances.
So it's really great for
complex computations.
And so that's Leanplum, and
that's how we took advantage
of Google's Cloud Platform.
As Momchil mentioned earlier,
we're looking to expand our
early adopter program.
So if you've got a mobile app,
and you're interested in A/B
testing and optimization, then
come and reach out to us.
Here's out email address,
founders@leanplum.com.
Or you can visit our website.
Thanks.
RYAN BOYD: OK, to wrap up this
first session here, I want to
talk about--
we have plenty of partners
that we're working on the
cloud platform with--
everything from technology
partners, who are building
Google Cloud Platform into their
software, as you saw a
little bit earlier, making it
easy for people to use the
Google Cloud Platform along
with their software, to
service partners that are
helping people integrate the
Google Cloud Platform into their
existing infrastructure.
So there's plenty of partners
that are helping us with this.
If you have any questions about
those partners, we do
actually have some folks from
our team available today that
can answer some of
those questions.
But rest assured that the cloud
platform is going to be
integrated into many of the
software packages which you
already use, as well as many
of the companies that you
already rely upon to handle
your services are learning
about and integrating the cloud
platform for customers.
I also want to talk to you
about the App Engine for
Startups Program.
This is a program that we
actually give credits for App
Engine to startups that
were building on top
of Google App Engine.
So during this month, there's
only a couple days left, but
you can apply for a $1,000
credit on App Engine.
So you can visit the URL here.
There's a special code we've
created for GDC.
Anyone that's attending GDC and
this session is welcome to
apply there if they want a
$1,000 credit to get going on
App Engine.
Now App Engine is free to start
for everyone, overall.
But there's a limit on the
number of requests and things
like that for free
applications.
So if you want to dive a little
bit deeper and want to
get a $1,000 credit, please
definitely fill out that form
and apply with the
code GDC-01.
Just wait a second there
if anyone wants to
write any of that down.
But next, we're going
to really go into
question and answer.
So we're happy--
Andrew, Momchil, and myself--
we're happy to take any
questions you have about the
cloud platform, about Leanplum,
or how Leanplum has
integrated with the Google
Cloud Platform.
Any questions?
And there's actually a mic here
in the center for you
guys to come up to if
you have questions.
AUDIENCE: So I actually
had a question about
your support in China.
RYAN BOYD: OK, I may not
be able to answer it.
But we can try.
AUDIENCE: Well, just
where are you at--
we run [? Dragonvale ?] servers
and people can't
access them from China.
Is there any sort of
planned support for
actually making that work?
Or do we have to proxy
around it?
What's the recommended
workaround?
RYAN BOYD: Actually, I don't
have an answer to give you
right now on that.
But I'm happy-- if you chat with
me later, I can give you
my email address.
And we can take that offline.
Sorry.
Thanks.
Any other questions?
Yeah, I mean you can scream it
out, and I'll repeat it.
Or you can go up there.
Either way.
AUDIENCE: Why don't you
repeat the question?
RYAN BOYD: Oh, sorry.
So he was asking about our
support for users in China and
cloud platform being accessible
to users in China.
And I don't know the details
around that, so I have to
follow up later.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RYAN BOYD: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So is there any
support for running C
extensions, Python extension,
in App Engine?
Or is that just [? hopeless ?]
[INAUDIBLE]?
RYAN BOYD: So the question is,
is there any support for
running C extensions within
Python on App Engine?
And basically, we have
a set of extensions
that we've made available.
And we deal with the
sandboxing of those
extensions.
It's a multi-tenant environment,
so we need to
make sure it's sandboxed
appropriately for security.
If it's not in that list, no, we
don't currently provide the
direct way for you to run
it on App Engine.
But that's where you can think
about having Compute Engine,
Backends handling some of your
traffic if there's particular
parts of your application
which would need that.
Any other questions?
All right, well, thank
you, everyone, for
coming to this part.
And I'll put up the slide
here with the rest.
[APPLAUSE]